let's talk about Ozzy than the impact
he's had on this ban when you guys I
think it was uh I get I guess Master of
Puppets after that I mean and you guys
weren't a big Commercial Success like
you are now Ozzy was the guy who said
hey come on tour with me right I'm going
to introduce you guys to America as a
bigger audience you must have thought
you died and went to heaven right this
was a huge break Aussie at that time
when he was his solo career was really
going was known to bring out
uh bands that were kind of uh on the
verge of breaking uh the time before he
took us out he took Motley Crew out and
did a whole US tour with Motley Crue and
that also elevated them to
to the level they eventually landed at
and um with us it was our turn in 86 we
had a new album Master of Puppets uh
Ozzy and obviously uh Sharon has a lot
to to to speak for in this also but they
were kind enough to take us out and give
us that shot and we were out and and
five years earlier James and I were
meeting and talking and sitting there
and trying to figure out what we're
doing and now we were out playing Arenas
in America you know we opened with
battery and then I think went into
master puppets and you know first couple
songs are kind of looking up and going
what is this racket and then 45 minutes
later they were all you know doing their
fists and getting into it and kind of
understanding you know what we were
doing and it was such a transformative
time and it was our first go-around of
the big leagues and hanging with Ozzy
and being around that a-level energy and
and that sort of a league like we were
in in the the we were in the majors you
know we've been playing in the minors
for years and now we were in the majors
and you know there's a lot of stories
that have gone around and some of them
have turned into tall tales and you know
Ozzy said a couple times we would be up
on stage at soundchecks playing some
Black Sabbath songs and he's been known
to say that he thought that we were
taunting him and we were kind of sort of
making fun of we were we were up on
stage playing Black Sabbath songs
because we wanted him to come up and
sing with us that was like our big dream
it's like
foreign
[Music]
he can hear us in his dressing room
somebody go get Ozzy and then Aussie
side of the story is he's down in his
dressing room going these guys are
taking the piss or they thought we were
making fun of him and we were just
trying to get our hero to come up on
stage and sing with us here you are with
Ozzy
listen to this James look
there you are
thrilling right
[Music]
wow